guys welcome to fake guru today we have
Brandon him young and he reached out on
via Instagram or he just commented under
my post where I was saying like oh yeah
it's so annoying that Kevin David is
such a small man that he has to take my
take my video down and I'm not talking
about Kevin you know copycat Kevin or
copyright Kevin I'm talking about this
Kevin David who allowed us to use his
name on Twitter you know there's a Kevin
David who actually said you could use my
name instead so now we can say Kevin
David on this program of course that's
who we're talking about we would never
talk about copyright Kevin so he
comments on my post about that he says
you know I was threatened but to be sued
by this guy when I posted something on
Instagram or something like that so I
just want you to get us into that
because I thought I was the only one I
thought you know surely this guy hasn't
done this to somebody else
apparently he has a lot of experience
silencing criticism so why don't you
talk talk to Saul yeah I mean obviously
when you have such a low success rate
and then there's no evidence of it and
no one's out there criticizing and then
you know I've seen reddit posts that
have been like silenced and polled
comments have been disabled
definitely videos have been pulled from
YouTube
so I posted on like the biggest thing
that bothered me I found out that that
Kevin had had posted a screenshot in his
many chat of where he faked sales like I
guess you can do some magic because yeah
yeah yeah so he he forgot to put the
comma when he faked his sales just
literally like committed fraud yeah
should be in jail because he's
defrauding people you post it and then
what had what happens does he contact
you and tell you like bring it down or
else like what happened so his attorney
messages or sent he sends me a demand
letter saying that he is going to sue me
for damages for lie I guess it was
liable and and for posting his
screenshot yeah well I called him a con
artist
I called him Conner that's why hey they
always get you on something yeah well I
mean I can prove it right so he was like
he wanted $250,000 a debit
which was laughable but I you know I
have liability insurance and everything
so that would cover it and would cover
all my legal expenses if it were to go
to it so basically I told my attorneys I
was like well tell them to eff off but
you know figure out a way to just make
it go away I'm not gonna pull the post
I'm not gonna not say anything that I
want to say because it's it's true what
bothered me the most is that you've got
you've got someone who repackaged
content that's not very good from other
courses that weren't very good is a two
comma Club X Award winner so he he won
that that means that you not only won
are you sold over a million dollars in
courses you sold ten million dollars in
courses so you've got someone that is
yeah he's defrauded people to the point
of over ten million dollars in courses
for a course where he was faking
screenshots to sell the course your your
meth your methodology for even finding a
product terrible then your methodology
for how to launch that product sale and
then you're telling people who can't
afford it to charge the inventory on a
credit card you should be in jail like
honestly you should just be in jail
because you're relieved he tells people
to charge it on a credit card
that yeah so insane so so beyond the
over selling of a dream which is already
criminal and then the get-rich-quick
stuff which is already criminal the
success rate being a three five percent
or even lower like 95 percent of the
people that take this course just lose
money and it causes real damage imagine
the people that are like married and the
number one reason for divorces is
financial stress right yeah so these
people are like well you know we're
working nine to five and we're barely
getting by but maybe we can spend a you
know we'll scrape together a thousand
dollars and a couple thousand dollars
more for inventory and now we're in debt
we have this credit card bill it
destroys families it's destroyed it
hurts people that's what that's what
pisses me off more than anything and why
I'm so vocal against it it's not like if
he if he avoided a man like his Amazon
course and just shut it down I wouldn't
have a problem with him as much some of
the evidence I'd gathered because I
didn't know if I would have
actually go to trial through them ago so
one of my friends showed me a
conversation with him back and forth
where he was asking for access to their
Amazon account so he could grab a
screenshot of their sales to use it to
sell his course well
what yeah he wanted a user he wanted to
become a secondary user on the person to
Amazon account with access only to see
sales Oh my buddy was just like I'm not
comfortable with that so then then he
writes back oh I already figured it out
and I guess what he figured out is that
he could just like use the chromic
chrome acted like edit it but then he
forgot the comma so then he got caught
because any many he blasted out on his
many chat through many chat uh like the
fake screenshot which you knows come
back to bite him and haunt them pretty
tremendously I think because yeah that's
why ever I could just tell him to F off
when he tries to come after them it's
like yeah go ahead I'll I'll go all the
way I'm happy to dig deep into let's
talk to all of your students let's see
how many are really successful how many
of them you've heard let's get testimony
from all of them let's let's talk about
this fraud that you committed and then
we're gonna package up really nicely
with a bow on top and I'm gonna send it
to a bunch of attorney generals and a
bunch of prosecutors and we'll see where
that goes for you and I'll send it to
Amazon as well and we'll see see how
they take yeah and and the thing is is
for the people real quick
defamation suits in this case they're
used as slap lawsuits so strategic
lawsuits against public participation
it's to silence people ultimately like
you may think oh well maybe Kevin's just
worried about his name and it's not what
it is it's because by slap law shooting
somebody you can basically shut down the
video shut down the conversation until
the lawsuit gets cleared up and so
people with bad reputations there or
they're trying to protect their
reputation with a lot of money with like
kind of a course that a lot of people
think are scams they are the kinds of
people you'll see routine
suing because they don't want the truth
getting out there and by and by suing
they're basically showing everybody else
hey don't talk about me because I'm
gonna basically sue anybody who talks
about me
so this is why I've been so vocal about
it like this is absurd I'm not gonna let
you silence me or anybody else because I
think it sends a bad message if I let
myself get silence think the more people
that see stuff like this that that don't
get scammed you know it's a victory so I
don't want like even don't come look
like it's not about coming to look for
me it's about like don't give guys like
that your money that is the big takeaway
name yeah
it's probably a scam let's just put it
that way
well said thanks for coming on Brandon
appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
but never shoot right
[Music]
sakura's
[Music]